maintenant avec nous ce soir le ministre
des finances du québec éric girard alors
que s'amorce demain le couvre-feu au
québec
bonsoir monsieur girard bonsoir je
souhaite d'abord une bonne année 2021
espérons qu'elle sera un peu plus calmes
que 2020 merci d'abord sur l'emploi
perte nette de 89 me l'emploi de
décembre 2010 9 à 2 décembre 2020 selon
statistique canada pour le québec 17 mai
donc en décembre premiers mois le
gatille depuis le printemps dernier
ça signale quoi de l'état de santé de
l'économie du québec
bon d'abord il ya vraiment plusieurs
informations dans le chef d'emploi
aujourd'hui de taux d'activité a diminué
ses sauf deux qui ont moins une personne
cherche un emploi
présentement c'est pour ça que le taux
de chômage au bc même si on en chef ni
cohérent avec la fermeture de commerces
et est donc ce qui se passe c'est que
dans un sens parce qu'il faut regarder
l'année nous étions plein emploi ou mois
de janvier au mois de février et est
arrivée la pandémie est une somme à 90
au sein niveau d'emplois total que nous
avions à en février donc il se savait
mais la loi la ti perdu que nous allons
dit il y aura d'autres emplois en
janvier alors lorsqu'il y aura la voie
lente
il faudra d'abord aller récupérer 120
150 me 9 mois pour revenir où nous
étions hockey quand le plie donc le
confinement annoncé et le confinement
prolongée et le couvre-feu jusqu'en
février tout ça ça va créer des pertes
d'emplois pour les québécois c'est
indéniable
parce que lorsqu'on ferme les commerces
de détail
jim lee tennis intérieur est ce que vous
allez aider davantage les gens compte
tenu de cette situation
mais ce qui se passe présentement c'est
tous les programmes sont en place
la prestation carhaisienne d'urgence et
ont migré l'assurance emploi et la
prestation canadienne de relance
économique et sort ses vrais amis sont
en place pour les individus ou les
entreprises
il ya aussi plusieurs programmes libres
est légal au tibet les subventions ou
les prêts par dana qui à 80% pour les
entreprises sont fermées ou des réseaux
center la complémentarité avec l'aide ou
loyers du gouvernement fédéral la
subvention salariale d'urgence ont tout
simplement utiliser plus du royaume
existe mais vous n'allez pas bonifier
les programmes existants mais seul mon
collègue et moi bien fatigué mais non on
s'en va on étudie les scénarios on va
évaluer la demande mais pour l'instant
discret qui est en place
chanter fiat est sûre motricité et et si
faut en faire plus chaud enfin et donc
vous évaluez le confinement prolongé au
8 février le couvre-feu vous avez dit ce
matin que le coût pour l'état c'est un à
deux milliards de dollars
comment vous arriver à cette estimation
la wii et essien dieu que c'est une
estimation sa vie on ne ressent 25
économistes chevronnés ou salés finance
je parle à plusieurs économistes dans le
monde académique de secteur privé ça
peut être plusieurs jours en effet lady
quelques les estimer mais
essentiellement on regarde là bas
du pib nous avons connu au moins d'avril
dernier
et là on est confinement similaire en
janvier mais avec des adaptations c'est
à dire que nos programmes d'être saute
déjà en place les le commerce en ligne
est beaucoup plus plaisant que les
manufacturiers reconstruction sont
ouverts dans ce koh seah et donc
l'impact pour un confinement et galou
play boy près de 50 % - et donc on a mis
un estimé vu confinement actuelle avec
certaines répercussions en février parce
que même si les commerces et condé
confinant furie on avoir possiblement
pas des cons finis à 108 5 février et
donc on estime la baisse du pib de
l'ordre de 1 à 2%
et ça ça donne une pince au niveau des
finances publiques de 1 à 2 pts 1 2
milliard de 2 milliards il vous
maintenez donc le 15 milliards de
déficit prévus parce que vous avez une
provision de 4 milliards de dollars
exactement dans votre esprit
faudra-t-il bientôt réduire la
croissance des dépenses
vous évoquez la voie tracée vers
l'équilibré budgétaire dans le prochain
budget est-ce qu'il faut bientôt réduire
la croissance des dépenses
moi je vous dis là qu'est ce qui s'est
vraiment nord pour faire les choses
c'est j'apprécie votre question la la la
la priorité des priorités c'est celui de
la pandémie
oui et de vacciner les personnes à
risques et le personnel du réseau de la
santé et ensuite le personnel
d'éducation alors la première priorité
c'est à forcer le système de santé
combattre la pandémie bercy ensuite en
soins et les québécois des entreprises
les aider elle ensuite la relance
non là on savait que la la la
qualification de la main
l'accélération les infrastructures la
productivité la compétition robin
ensuite le retour à l'équilibré
budgétaire donc chaque chose en son
temps
mais je pense que le retour à
l'équilibré budgétaire devant les
efforts devront s'est associé à mesure
qu'on va se rapprocher du plein emploi
et qu'on va se rapprocher du potentiel
économique du québec
lorsque sa vie lorsqu'on utilise
l'expression l'économie fonctionne à
pleine capacité
oui parce qu'on est au d'emploi on est
on est je sors à la surchauffe
c'est certainement alors que le
gouvernement dit qu'il veut ces dépenses
donc c'est pas pour tout de suite de
toute évidence on a le temps de faire
parler je passe eric girard merci
beaucoup merci énormément pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit